[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right every day I like to
find something awesome on social media
that you may have overlooked I don't
want you to miss out you're welcome this
is what I'm
liking there is nothing like the joy of
knowing that you've got a baby on the
way um there's also nothing quite like
the agony of morning sickness it sucks
uh but check out how one two-year-old
tried to comfort her mama when a wave of
nausea
hit it's
okay I love you I love you too I love
you it's
okay it's okay Mom thanks sweetie it's
okay I
mean that video is tricky it makes you
want to have more kids and you shouldn't
always do that um but we have Little
Rosie on the line now along with her
mama Catherine watching on St Louis box
to what's up y'all hi Kelly hi oh my
gosh you're adorable so Catherine did
you did you get sick a lot did L morning
sickness I did I did I got so sick um
not so much with Rosie but the second
pregnancy was just brutal and I was sick
the whole nine months which is great um
Rosie got used to me yeah she got used
to me running to the bathroom quite
often yeah it's miserable um so Rosie
what's your favorite part of being a
sister she likes giving him hugs and
kisses and um helping me put him to bed
at night which sometimes that's more
distracting than helpful but but it's
been it's been sweet how far apart are
they mine are 22 months apart so my my
eldest has been moming my the youngest
for a minute yeah yeah they're they're
almost just shy of three years apart so
um it's a good good age where she can
help and kind of understand what's going
on um but then they'll also be able to
grow up together which I'm really
excited to watch them kind of create
that Bond yeah I know I love that I have
an older girl and the younger is a boy I
think that's just really sweet it's nice
to watch but you do have to be like
you're not the mom calm down um well
Rosie thank you so much for being so
sweet and helping your mama when she
wasn't feeling well Katherine you're
doing such a great job beautiful kiddo
uh thank you so much for sharing this
I'm liking your post right now
right all right well that's that's not
all Rosie our season long partner pilot
pin makers of friction the go-to
erasable pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate your growing family so
they're going to give you
$1,000 thank you so much oh my gosh your
eyes are so beautiful a now I want
another baby this is not good um thank
you guys so much have a wonderful
evening and thank you so much to all our
guests this hour Daniel R L Jonathan
Alex Earl
joy and Lor here all the great day it's
not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home